here we are at Bletchley Park but in a
part of the Bletchley Park site that's
the National Museum of computing in the
UK and they've had a sense to have the
siting here for the rebuild of the
Colossus machine that was as many of you
know the big feature of Bletchley Park
later on in the war because it was
involved in helping to decrypt the
Lorenz cipher which was a much much
bigger challenge than even enigma it
supposed to see yes there's quite a lot
to see you got to remember this is
arguably the world's very first
electronic computer it really is largely
electronic it relies on thermionic
valves that's vacuum tubes to those of
you in North America so yes the the
logic and the counting is done with
vacuum tubes the feature though of
computers of this era and it is a
special-purpose computer remember it's
not general purpose and the one thing
that was very difficult was to get them
to have memory because memory hadn't
been invented so the data that it has to
analyze is actually on a five whole
paper tape and you just have it spinning
around at very high speed and if you
miss a particular piece of data you have
to wait for it to come round again so
that tape that you see there is going at
five thousand characters per second
let's get over there earlier
roughly I think corresponds to 30 miles
an hour and this is absolutely amazing
that it does not fly apart there is one
problem of joining the ends of the tape
and Phil over there as the expert tells
me that whereas in the Second World War
they used to use a benzene based Bostic
sort of glue health and safety won't
permit that anymore and it's highly
inflammable and so he's just been doing
he tells me some experiments on what the
best substitute would be for joining
tape ends answer number one was that
Brown parcel tape which worked quite
well answer number two which is
try it out I think is pretty sick and
Princeton just superb so there we are
then continuous readout of data quite a
high latency because if you miss
something you've got to wait for it to
come around again but all of the
electronics here is dedicated it's
special-purpose it's recognizing
patterns in the ciphertext that came off
the Lorenz cipher machine and once
you've specified lots of the patterns
you're looking for it will do the
automatic counting for you the Lorenz
machine was basically an adapter that
you could add on to a teleprinter we've
heard all about enigma which in many
ways was a very low-level very
labor-intensive machine Hitler wanted
something faster more personal more
secure so the Lorenz machine was used by
the high command to talk to each other
it was used by Hitler to give commands
to his generals it was crucial round
about d-day to be able to decrypt the
Lorenz traffic because essentially it
did show that Hitler had been taken in
by an IED plan to convince him that
d-day wasn't going to happen in Normandy
but there was a whole how should we say
feint operation to say no no no let's
try and convince the Germans it's going
to happen in Calais and they found out
by decrypting Lorenz traffic using
Colossus mark 2 that yes Hitler had
fallen for this deception and kept on
sentry General's no no no you know it's
not going to be a Normandy it's going to
be in the pas-de-calais that according
to military people made a world of
difference about the level of opposition
they faced and how quickly they advanced
the question it could take place after
d-day well what we'll find in more
detail later on but all of these valves
is this is why it really is thought of
as one of the world's first
special-purpose valve driven computer
Tommy flowers as its famous designer and
people said to him at the time flowers
proposing what's wrong with
electromechanical technology relays you
know I can the bomb and basically Tommy
so look for the job we have to do with a
Laurent cipher it's not going to be fast
enough I'll build it for you using
vowels and then people said but how many
will you need flowers you know six hours
a dozen he said 1500 may we have him and
he was not afraid of vowels he didn't
mind how many we used people when they
set him but hours come come come we all
know about thermionic valves they blow
and they go bang and you have to replace
them they're not reliable enough and he
was basically a post office telecoms
engineer and he said look I've worked in
the research section I've led it valves
are fine as long as you never switch
them off there they've got heaters in
miracles and so long as maybe it you
know when it's not working flat out you
turn the heating voltage down but don't
switch it off you will be surprised at
how reliable it can be and he was pretty
riot it was tested out at Tommy's own
clays Dollis Hill in late 43 I think
it's been established it was on 8th of
December 1943 dollars hill testing moved
to Bletchley Park here in early 1944 and
came into action pretty soon thereafter
this is a replica of it this is a
replica yes as a result I think of the
Freedom of Information Act in America it
was possible to get hold eventually I
think of a complete set of drawings was
it fair is very much an unsung hero yes
he did suffer because first of all
people wouldn't believe him then when he
did deliver of course he was a hero but
was effectively felt that he would never
get his just deserts of fame and all out
because of the secrecy it's hard to
believe now how ultra ultra ultra secret
this was and I think it was very hard
for Tommy when later on I think was
about 1946 there was an American
electronic special-purpose computer came
along called ENIAC which calculated
gunnery trajectories now of course
new engine mail Colossus this is being
widely reported as the world's first
special-purpose computer with valves
this was two years earlier than any AK
but nobody could say a word about it not
a word and I think a lot of people at
Bletchley still felt at the end of the
war that frankly Tommy flowers max
Newman who was the head of the Newman
rehear which was in charge of all this
and the guy who made the real one of the
really initial analyses that enable
classic should we build built chuck or
built at they should all have been
knighted
they weren't they got various sort of
awards and so on the only good spin I
can put on this as to why they weren't
all over more is the secrecy again I can
just imagine the Whitehall civil servant
say looking for some lighting all these
people they're gonna start asking
questions in public why this flowers
superb engineer but why night on fire
you know and don't forget this was in an
era up into about fairly recently where
the whole idea was that this should be
kept secret forever
they didn't want it ever to come out or
I think Winston Churchill's compromise
was something like I had forgive there
could you imagine having to wait until
2045 on 2044 for this to be made
available anyway
common sense is now prevailed and glad
to say and it's a wonderful thing to
behold flowers said one of the best days
of my life was seeing all these clever
people Alan Turing max Newman built art
all of them with their mouths dropping
off saying flowers what have you done
and I think you said the worst bit after
that was this is wonderful this is so
quick now we can really get working
flowers we like for more of these
preferably in two months time and I
don't think people said get real in
early 1944 but that was the sentiment
effect
zero to one and so on and the important
thing about this is by doing this we're
going to get a huge list of North's all
in a row and that is very easily
compressed by Huffman encoding